and welcome the director general of
business Europe Marcus bear and the
general secretary Luca vincentino from
the European trade Union Confederation
not least of course also by the prime
minister of the Czech Republic the
presidency the rotating presidency
president you have the flow
good afternoon everyone today we had the
occasion to meet with our social
Partners at a challenging time for the
world and for our European Union
it's a time of War Russia is brutally
attacking the people of Ukraine and
Ukraine is Bravely defending itself
and Russia swore has Unleashed high
energy prices and put pressure on our
families and businesses across the EU
and Beyond and this was the main topic
of our Summit today with the social
partners
the active participation of the social
Partners will again be essential in
facing today's challenges just like
during covet 19.
energy will be the focus of our European
council meeting tomorrow and Friday and
we have three goals lowering prices
guaranteeing security of supply and
having a function in single Market with
no distortion
and the question is how do we achieve
this we are not starting from scratch
the EU along with other member states
have already taken measures on Energy
savings and just storage for the coming
winter and then some key issues we have
taken decisions that need to be enforced
joint purchases of energy resources for
instance on others especially on
reducing Energy prices we affect many
strategic distributions in fact this
topic has been the top of the European
Council agenda for a long time
since Marcus invited permission to come
up with proposal to tackle high prices
and address the energy crisis and the
commission as notable is proposals
the time has come to take the ball
decisions our citizens and businesses
expect
and there is one question one important
question do we do it the European way
acting together in the common interests
or do we do it alone we should avoid
temptation of national only approaches
to tackle this crisis because this would
be a huge mistake
the national only approach will not work
because it would endanger our single
Market which benefits us all it is our
strongest asset job I didn't jeopardize
industrial markets is jeopardizing this
prosperity and the future of all member
states without exception
tomorrow we'll discuss and I hope we'll
decide on the options on the table first
negotiating with Partners on secretive
Supply and lower import prices
to keep the desk imposed on the same
level you can't really suspend much more
this new situation has generated
windfall profits for gas providers and
for their respective countries and this
imbalance between close partners and
closely linked economies is not a good
situation this is common sense I am sure
I am confident we can find a mutually
satisfactory solution to this problem
certain we'll discuss putting into
action joint purchases of gas because
this will strengthen our collective
bargaining power and ensure we don't
drive our prices by competing against
each other and third we will determine
our table Solution on gas price caps
taking into account our energy of supply
an important number of members are in
favor of tapping gas prices and there
are different options on the table we
need a clear way forward with clear
deadlines
is
president
Madam president you have the floor thank
you so much indeed uh it was wonderful
to meet in person again so we have
missed you and it was not the same as
long as we saw each other on the screen
but it was really good to have this
tripartite social Summit today in person
it showed also how important it is that
we work very closely together with the
social Partners in this crisis as we've
done it in the pandemic during the
pandemic and really with success
we have been discussing basically two
main strands the one is of course
addressing the energy crisis and the
other strand was how can we make sure
that our social market economy stays fit
for purpose
so on the first trend on the topic of
energy
the commission has tabled its proposals
on uh when on Tuesday sorry it was
yesterday
um and uh I explained to the tripartite
summit the different proposals that we
had there was overall acknowledgment
that we have already achieved a lot we
should not forget that since March we've
been working on pooling the demand
on filling our storages we had 92 by now
on really being serious on Energy
Efficiency we have reduced energy and
gas use by 15 already in September and
most importantly uh the proposal that
has been adopted now that member states
can take the windfall profits of energy
producing companies to support
vulnerable households and businesses
but we also see that more needs to be
done and on this basis we can step up in
two topics the one was and is the topic
about capping prices we have been
discussing the two different versions
that are possible and where we have made
proposals
and the second topic was of course how
can we make sure that there is enough
support for smes and businesses through
repower EU
and this leads me to the social market
economy our social market economy must
continue to reward performance on one
hand but also guarantee protection this
is the core value of the social market
economy and it is more needed than ever
in crisis like this one
so for that we need first and foremost
of course the social dialogue therefore
the commission will present in the
coming months an initiative on improving
social dialogue at National and at EU
level
and we will now work together on
focusing on the most pressing issue that
is how can we keep the Level Playing
Field in our uh single Market we need as
I said to support businesses in
particular smes
therefore we will present an SME relief
package in the second half of the next
years here and we will make further
proposals for targeted support for
companies impacted by the energy crisis
this is basically on uh the basis of The
Proposal of repower EU repower EU has
been proposed in March it is agreed in
the College of the commission since May
on the table of Parliament and Council
and we really call on Parliament and
Council now to finalize repower EU
because we need this investment vehicle
it is so important because it can be the
Investments that we need now
cross-border in infrastructure in Energy
Efficiency and into the Renewables this
will also give fiscal space to member
states that they need to support the
vulnerable households and therefore it
is of utmost importance that we have
this EU financed instrument up and
running because not all member states
have the fiscal space to support their
smes and their businesses and here would
be the opportunity to go forward with
something where the social Partners
agree that it is necessary my last point
is we've been discussing the topic of
skills
a well-functioning labor market needs a
good skills we have a low unemployment
rate of six percent but we should not
oversee that this covers only or
camouflages the fact that there is a big
need of Skilling people upskilling and
reskilling with a changing economy and
the changing labor market there's a
reason why we have called 2023 as the
European year of skills here too social
Partners will have a very important role
to play it is impossible to bring
forward the skills agenda without the
social Partners we need you
because you know best how to match
people's aspiration and skills with the
company's needs so in some
we are in tough times the more we need
the social dialogue and the social
Partners many things
thank you madam president
prime minister you have the flu
thank you ladies and gentlemen first of
all I would like to thank president and
presidential Michelle for sharing
today's event I want also to thank the
representative of social partners for
their participation today there are very
difficult times for the European Union
we are still recovering from the covet
pandemic and we have to face impact of
the Russian aggression on Ukraine
today's Summit showed the importance of
an open and inclusive social dialogue in
these difficult times it's important to
respond effectively to the Social and
economic impacts in current situation we
have to make sure that all our decisions
are fair and well targeted highlighting
the social dimension of the current
crisis is a priority of the Czech
presidency in Council we are working
together with all our partners on
lowering the impact of the of the energy
crisis on our citizens on our businesses
labor markets and our social health and
Educational Systems
on EU level we have already called three
extraordinary extraordinary energy
councils we succeeded in taking decision
at Short Time aiming both at reducing
energy demand and reducing the impact of
high energy prices on consumers
consumers
I will come yesterday's proposal by the
commission we will talk about these
proposals the European council meeting
tomorrow more detailed discussion is
expected the energy Council next Tuesday
the Czech presidency is ready to work
with the member state to adopt the
legislation as soon as possible we will
be working closely with the commission
on more possible proposals on Energy
prices to make sure that no one is Left
Behind ahead of the upcoming winter
is
uh then Summit uh
um foreign
foreign
thank you prime minister
Mr vicentini can I invite you to take
the flu
thank you very much I would like really
as well to thank you the three
institutions that have hosted this
meeting President Michelle president
from The Lion prime minister fiala and
also of course the colleagues from the
employer side in particularly Marcos
buyer
uh you know from the point of view of
the trade unions and workers we run the
risk to face an incredible recession
together with inflation and this is
called stagflation there are two
fundamental effects on working people
coming from a stagflation the first one
is about employment for the moment in
the short run we see employment not
falling dramatically but at the same
time we see falling quite dramatically
the working hours and also the wages and
income of people and in the medium round
for sure this will turn into into also
unemployment because companies will
struggle to survive and will close down
probably or with dismiss a large part of
their stuff
so the first problem will be
unemployment or underemployment the
second problem is poverty because
inflation is not only linked to Energy
prices we see not only vulnerable people
entering into a situation of poverty but
even the middle class in many many
European countries when you have an
inflation two digits of course is not
only paying the bills for energy but is
also having access to housing having the
access to food having Access to Health
Care etc etc so how to tackle all this
there are things we have discussed this
afternoon on which we really converge in
terms of analysis but also in terms of
proposals we really appreciate what the
European institutions are going to
discuss in the council tomorrow a cup to
Energy prices the need to have a
taxation of on windfall profits and also
the possibility to radically reform the
energy price Market all this is
something that that we as trade unions
really support is really needed and we
are in full solidarity with these
measures there are other things that are
needed at the same time wages is an
emergency at the moment in Europe we had
already a dropping real wages before the
war started and before this crisis
kicked in this was due to the financial
crisis before and then to the covet
crisis that follow so the situation with
wages in Europe is very serious
especially in some countries but more in
general also on average and now of
course having this inflation adds even
more problems on the top of the wage
real cuts that we had in the past that's
why we are insisting so much on the fact
that we need to have negotiated wages to
go up in each and every European country
we are convinced that this will not lead
to a wage inflation spiral because the
inflation now is linked to other factors
but at the same time we are also
perfectly aware that is not up to the
European Union to increase wages
nevertheless there is a fundamental
instrument that is in the end so each
and every member states and the European
Union has delivered recently that is the
directive on minimum wages and quality
bargaining these directive envisages
action plans at National level to
strengthen collective bargaining
collective bargaining we have agreed
today is the most important instruments
the social Partners have in their end to
make sure that we can negotiate properly
wage increases in each and every country
without arming the economy well it's
important addition every member states
and we appeal really the Czech
presidency for this and is encouraged to
adopt immediately these action plans and
not to wait two years for the
transposition of this directive finally
an element on which we agree partially
is the fact that all the measures that
President Van Der Lyon explained today
are absolutely important those for
energy Market but at the same time also
for companies and for the economy what
we Miss still are social measures we
agree of course that is up to the member
states to put in place these social
measures anti-poverty measures
employment protection measures Etc is
the competence of member states but what
we have done during the pandemic in 2020
as indicated very clearly that without
European support in terms of solidarity
and also financing it's impossible for
the member states they don't have fiscal
space and National level to put in place
these measures there are countries that
are rich that can do it other countries
don't have the money to do so and it's
not enough to put in place some taxation
or other measures for companies we need
something similar to what we had in 2020
it was called sure we can call it
differently we can find another name we
can find a different mechanism we can
improve it of course it's not only about
employment protection it's also about
supporting anti-poverty measures and
climate and digital just transition but
we need something similar now
immediately otherwise the people will
just go into poverty and there will be
no chance in the medium and and long run
to recover from this situation that's
why we have appealed so strongly to the
European and National institutions to
come together into a table and to make
sure that through social dialogue we can
design an instrument like that we really
desperately need it thank you thank you
Mr vicentini you said about her you have
the flu thank you ladies and gentlemen
let me also start by thanking president
from The Lion president Michelle and
prime minister fiela for a very good
meeting and it really feels so different
to be the same table again to
discussed to interact face-to-face to
continue the discussion in the elevator
so this really makes a hell of a
difference and we're really grateful for
this and I think it's a crucial moment
to do so because we have seen on both
sides
off the table a lot of convergence I
think we have seen that we all agree
that we have a crucial problem we have
seen that we need unity and solidarity
we all agree that we will need more
social dialogue and not less
and we have been very clear on both
sides of the table workers and employers
trade unions that we have a real crisis
here we have a crisis which is probably
deeper than the crisis we have seen in
covet because it touches uh much more on
the basis of our wealth
and we need to find Solutions and we
have a crisis that touches all sizes of
companies
and we have a crisis and this has been
underlined by our friends from the trade
unions that also addresses effects at
least 35 million plus workers in the
opinion and so we really need to find
Solutions and I think we've also agreed
that there will need to be support for
the most vulnerable Enterprises and
households and some of the instruments
have been mentioned and I think we also
had agreement that we need to protect
our single market and the Level Playing
Field because if we give up on this in
the crisis we will have big problems in
the long term
coming back to the basis of the crisis I
think we have a situation where
consumer sentiment has fallen companies
increasingly have an issue to absorb the
high energy and raw material costs which
is eroding their margins
so let me be clear that many European
companies at this very moment fight for
their survival and we also see
unfortunately that we have production
moving out of Europe so we see
relocation
and if we don't find Solutions we will
see more relocation because for the time
being of course there are still
companies which are protected by even
either Hedges or by long-term energy
Supply contracts but the problem is
getting bigger by the months and
therefore let me come to the as a charm
Michelle said and also also left on the
line the core of the debate today of
course was how can we intelligence
tackle the energy cost problem we are
having because we need to address the
root causes in order to survive this
crisis and we are grateful for
everything which has been done already
the Prime Minister field I said three
extraordinary energy councils and there
might be more uh president of the
council work the the commission has made
a lot of good proposals and as you said
president very fairly if we can discuss
the measures we still need now this is
thanks to the basis which has been
created rapidly over the months so this
is very clear and we are very grateful
for this but we also know that we will
need further steps now we will need to
improve the temporary crisis framework
the uh the stated guidelines and I'm
very grateful to hear that this is
underway to make sure that the member
states can support the companies in need
appropriately of course while protecting
the single market and we need to address
this cost issue at the roots which means
we need to come up with a solution for
the energy price cap
um if possible based on the decoupling
of gas and electricity prices
and we also discussed this of course
there's still issues to be
settled we need to make sure that this
does not lead to a supply shortage in
gas we need to make sure that there's a
balance between those who pay and those
who will benefit all this will need to
be addressed
but we need to find a solution and this
is what I'm really asking the
institutions
the council which is happening as of
tomorrow
to really work hard on the solution and
to make a step forward hopefully find a
solution and I think it's fair to say
that you have a very clear
and and the very strong mandate from the
social Partners to bring to the table of
the council and to really have a strong
message saying we need to solve this
issue in order to make sure that
companies and workers can survive this
crisis thank you
thank you for your words
you had a question
you will have to go to the stand yes
a question both for president Charles
Michelle and president Wonderland
um president Michelle
um you said that your aim was to get to
decisions tomorrow and you mentioned the
the cup and the prize gas there is not
even a proposal on the table for such uh
such a decision is this the landing Zone
you are looking for for tomorrow this is
why everybody is telling us that it's
going to be a long long night that we
should take like extra snacks and so on
and president Wonderland how how do you
see is this your aim for tomorrow do you
think it's a realistic expectation that
you get an agreement on these very
difficult issue tomorrow night thank you
we we we discussed for many months this
uh this uh energy crisis and the
importance to address together the
crisis in the European way and you know
that a few weeks ago we were in Pride
and with the education to spend hours to
discuss the topic and we have identified
what are the different elements that we
need to to resolve first we need to
reduce the consumption this was
explained and we are making progress in
that field this is not enough that's why
we need also to guarantee the security
of Supply I've also mentioned the
efforts made related to the to the to
the storages and we've also mentioned
importance to speed up the negotiations
with countries with partners with
countries which are important providers
for us and I've mentioned those
countries are making money because of
the prices but they are our partners
they are our friends and that's why we
determine interest to find with them a
balanced solution in order to have more
predictability for them for us and also
in order to protect our permanent
interest in terms of Economic
Development and I think the social
Partners made very clear points
regarding that economic and social
creation and third is what you mentioned
the prices of course there is a lot of
pressure pressure on the families and
the households on the businesses the
smes but also the the the industrial
sectors and we know there are different
options on the table and I
you you know that the commission put on
the table proposals the two days or a
few days a few days ago is this a good
package because this is a good basis
building on the tools we had in the past
in order to in order to take additional
steps and to clarify what we want for
the future
the European tours in tumor will be
difficult it will be complex because
there are different sensitivities
different opinions we do not have all
the same starting points but I see two
important elements first question are we
ready to work together in order to
implement measures to lower the prices
of gas 0.1 and I expect a yes to the
decision and I expect us to clarify what
are the options on which we will build
in order to be effective on the equation
point one and point two there is a
certain question which is related to the
single market and the solidarity the
financial solidarity because we all
understand that we do not have the same
starting points in terms of energy mix
we do not have also no we don't have the
same starting pulse in terms of fiscal
space it means the sum of our members
says are able to compensate to support
to help but there is a risk of
fermentation on the single Market if all
is is all the members says do not have
the same
capabilities and capacities to protect
the future of the cities in the future
of the of the businesses and an
additional element in fact
systematically on the EU side when we
Face a serious crisis a big crisis it
was the case with the financial crisis
it was the case with the covet uh Christ
the infiltration of solidarity and
question of unity and with one lesson
learned systematically when we are able
to act quickly and to work together we
were also able to overcome the
difficulties and to improve the
situation and the traditions of Life of
our people it was very clear with the
curvature prize and again there's a
moment of truth it's a moment of truth
and I expect us to tell the right
decisions
so indeed
um
what we expect tomorrow from the
European Council is political guidance
political steer the commission has
tabled under the article 122.
proposals
um I want to mention the three main one
the one is pooling and aggregating our
demand to purchase gas with a binding
element in it for 15 percent of storage
cars
the second one is that we have
the sharing and solidarity obligation
between member states in case of a
severe crisis
and their rules have to be put in place
we put them on the table
and the third element is a cap
to tame the volatility
of The ttf Benchmark and also to fight
the manipulation
um of the gas market by Russia
these three things here as I said will
be detailed out then in either the
finance ministers
Council or the energy ministers Council
what we expect from the leaders
is political guidance and steer
and then there is the other topic
concerning our single Market
and the competitiveness of our economy
competitiveness not only within the
single Market but also towards other
regions of the world whether it is the
Asian region or for example
transatlantic region and here the
um proposal of repower EU is so crucial
because it gives the governance to
invest in the transition that we need
and to maintain at the same time the
Level Playing Field within our European
single Market to make sure that all
member states have the possibility to
invest in their future
and what the transition is concerned
during the oil crisis 30 years ago more
than that we made the mistakes not to
invest in renewable energy but to stick
with the fossil fuels this time we
really should have learned our lesson
and therefore right now yes we have to
fight the immediate crisis but as
important is that we immediately invest
in the future-proof clean technologies
that are homegrown and therefore give us
security of supply and Independence
thank you madam president Peter you had
a question as well better from the Czech
television please thank you my question
goes to the representatives of the
institutions as well as to our prime
minister patofila yesterday the Spanish
Minister for ecological transition said
that the things are not moving fast
enough are not moving forward fast
enough with our response to the energy
crisis so how are you personally
satisfied with the pace what what has
been done and do you have any personal
red line or deadline after which it
won't be possible to save this winter
thank you
maybe interesting in what
just in in a in in one word we have
mentioned what you have already done and
we we did a lot with sentiments but this
is not enough we need more and uh I
fully support the idea that is extremely
urgent that's why this meeting tomorrow
will be an important one
so we assist through a lot has been
already done in terms of gas storage
analysis energy saving and reliable gas
Imports but we still need to take
further steps to address long-term high
gas and electricity prices the measures
already adopted by the energy Council
will help households and small and
medium-sized Enterprises but and it was
mentioned in our discussion very often
it is also necessary to extend the
temporary crisis framework to help the
European industry it it's very very
important and of course in a short time
short term we have to accept measures
that help our citizens and companies
economically survive this crisis we know
about it
I expect it very long deep
good but difficult discussion but we we
know that
common common results or Unity is our
strong power and that is something which
we we need to to find in the end of our
discussion
I think the urgency is visible through
the fact that we table our proposals
under the article 122.
which is an immediate Council decision
so the fastest track you can think of
with the windfall profit that we have
tabled some weeks ago it took us three
weeks
till it was European law right now we
are calling for the implementation in
the member states that it is really used
this instrument
and a secondary mark on speed we should
not forget what the root cause for all
that is
that is the atrocious war that Russia
has Unleashed
and the fact that Russia has
systematically tried to Blackmail us
through energy for example the fact that
Gus from last year did not fill the
storages as it would have had to or that
long-term contracts pipeline guards are
not being honored
and in the last eight months these eight
months of the Russian war
we have been able to compensate the cut
of two-thirds
of Russian guys Pipeline and LNG towards
the European Union
with enormous efforts by getting the
necessary supplier on a daily basis from
other friends and reliable suppliers
with filling our storages
and with saving energy as much as we can
and only with that Foundation was and is
it possible now to go the next steps
because we have the storages filled to
speak about the price caps
and of course
um I can only repeat repower EU is
urgently to be finalized now
we'll take a last question Angela from
The Huffington Post yes please yes thank
you I'm sorry I have to bring you to the
Italian political situation because
there are some last remarks by berluscon
yesterday he said that he is in contact
with Putin The Exchange presence and I'm
sure you heard the story and today there
is an audio which has just come out in
which he says that it's jalenski's fault
if there is a war in Ukraine and the war
is uh basically continuing because there
is an a Ukrainian resistance
I was wondering as Berlusconi is
negotiating a new government in Italy
LED with this Coalition uh what are your
expectations and what are your comments
about this thanks
I do not intend to to tremend the
comments point one there is a clear EU
position that we have reiterated many
times we support uh Ukraine as much as
we can with financial support with
military and political and humanitarian
uh support we we condemn Russia we don't
accept this uh unjustified and
non-provoked War launched by Russia
against uh against uh Ukraine and of
course we will work it will cooperate
with the the governance the government
with all the governments and also with
the Italian uh government based on the
respect for the Democratic institutions
in Italy
thank you for um being here we'll see
you tomorrow and the day after
that
[Music]